[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
de son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et on est dans
un système très curatif 1 c'est
essentiel d'avoir l'information pour pas
subir
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit qui doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur le comté d g
d'ayrté france vous pouvez prendre part
au débat interpeller nos invités au
sommaire de ce mercredi 20 octobre à
sommes nous en train de banaliser l'état
d'urgence en france plusieurs voix à
gauche comme à droite s'élève à
l'assemblée nationale pour dénoncer un
régime d'exception devenu éternel climat
houleux dans l'hémicycle pour les
députés examinent un nouveau projet de
loi avec la possibilité de recourir au
passé ni terre jusqu'au 31 juillet un
texte qui prévoirait le cas échéant de
conditionner se servent à l'injection
d'une troisième d'auge alors la
troisième dose ma dose de trop on attend
vos réactions sur le conte télégramme
daté france qu'ils ont déjà été très
nombreuses ce soir
les talibans doivent remplir leurs
engagements devant la communauté
internationale appelle lancé aujourd'hui
par moscou cueille des discussions sur
la situation en afghanistan
les tout premiers pourparlers en russie
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
fondamentalistes en août dernier des
hauts responsables d'une dizaine de pays
ont fait le déplacement dans la capitale
russe chinois iraniens panis est née
entre eux mais pas d'américains
les annonces du gouvernement attendu de
manière imminente alors que les prix de
l'essence et du gasoil bat des records
en france un chèque pour les plus
modestes une baisse des dates plusieurs
pistes sont sur la table une flambée des
prix d'énergie qui touche toute l'europe
bruxelles réfléchir à d'ailleurs demain
à des mesures on en parle dans notre
deuxième partie d'émission
[Musique]
la prolongation du paf sanitaires pour
huit mois divise au sein de l'assemblée
nationale les députés examinent en ce
moment et depuis hier les nouveaux le
nouveau projet de loi consacré à la
crise du coc vide on retrouve notre
reporter le cas légers au palais-bourbon
bonsoir le cas alors ce qui fait des
grâces et des dents à gauche comme à
droite d'ailleurs c'est cette
possibilité de conditionner le pass
sanitaires à des français à l'injection
d'une troisième dose
absolument y les amendements défilent
depuis cet après midi devant l'assemblée
nationale hier aussi il a eu des débats
jusque tard dans la nuit et les députés
ont voté le premier article de cette loi
l'exécutif tient à ce texte car il veut
éviter un confinement en catastrophe il
veut pouvoir se donner les moyens de
résister aux variants delta qui continue
de faire son chemin en europe olivier
verrons a notamment évoqué le cas de la
lettonie y est requis
recombiner sa population donc vous
l'avez dit ce texte il donne la
possibilité au gouvernement d'utiliser
le pass and i ter et l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 et il
prévoit aussi des sanctions plus lourdes
pour les fraudeurs ceux qui falsifient
rats dépasse sanitaires pour les
revendre par exemple les défenseurs de
ce texte évoque une boîte à outils dans
laquelle on pourrait puiser des des
possibilités pour réagir alors que le
parlement ne siégera plus à partir du 28
février mais l'opposition elles estiment
que le gouvernement met totalement de
côté le parlement j'ai pu parler avec
certains députés et vous allez voir que
les propos sont similaires malgré les
divergences politiques
aujourd'hui je suis stupéfait de voir
cette prolongation jusqu'en juillet 2022
qui en réalité
considère ou sous-entendre qu'il n'y
aurait plus de parlement après février
au motif qu'ils auraient des élections
il ya des élections présidentielles
n'empêche pas moins que le président
sera toujours en exercice est toujours
en capacité pour des décisions il y aura
donc toujours un parlement qui est
toujours possible de réunir pour le
faire statuer sûr je dirais les
nécessité ou pas de prolonger ce pas
sanitaire parce que je remarque c'est
que les gens qui sont d'accord dans
cette salle c'est ce qu'ils défendent
finalement les droits du parlement c'est
à dire l'assurance que nous donnons à
ceux qui nous ont élus au peuple que la
séparation des pouvoir continuer à
exister que le gouvernement on laisse
pas tout dans les mains d'un seul homme
parce qu'en réalité ses modèles macro à
l'elysée qui plus est en plus dans une
période qui va et électorale la bataille
outil c'est plus le parlement qu'il leur
à ce sont les membres du gouvernement
donc qu'il nous dise n'utilisera pas les
outils mais c'est pas la question on
leur donne la boîte et c'est eux qui
vont ouvrir la boîte et prendre le
tournevis ou le marteau et nous le
mettre sur la tête donc ce que je veux
bien dire c'est que ils nous disent oui
mais on va pas obligatoirement utiliser
peut-être mais en attendant on leur
donne la boîte à outils alors que si
c'était le parlement qui gardaient la
maîtrise et bien on aurait la maîtrise
des choses on saurait ouvre l issue du
conseil des ministres le cas ce matin le
porte parole du gouvernement était on ne
peut plus clair la fin du pass annie
terre ce n'est pas pour demain
oui absolument au vu de la dynamique de
l'épidémie qui reprend un peu c'est un
frémissement et bien il ne voit pas
comment on pourrait faire un allègement
du pass sanitaire au 15 novembre mais il
a tenu à rappeler il l'avait déjà dit la
semaine dernière que le gouvernement
n'avait aucun fétichisme du qr codes du
passani terre ou des mesures de
restriction de liberté bien sûr ceux qui
ne sont pas de cet avis ce sont les
manifestants anti passe sanitaire qui
battent le pavé depuis des mois il a eu
encore une petite manifestation de gilet
jaune ici à l'assemblée nationale à
l'extérieur des murs il y as ils étaient
plusieurs centaines de personnes à
l'appel du parti les patriotes 2 florian
philippot ces personnes elles veulent
toujours être mobilisés jusqu'à ce que
le pays soit totalement ouvert merci le
cas légers en direct de l'assemblée
nationale est depuis maintenant un mois
de nombreux professionnels sont soumis à
l'obligation vaccinale à commencer par
les médecins et autres soignants malgré
tout cent trente mille d'entre eux
n'avaient reçu aucune dose début octobre
selon la direction générale de la santé
et certains s'opposent fermement donc sn
vaccination et sont donc privées dupas
sanitaires alors qu'en pensent les
français eux et non ça vous allez à la
rencontre sur le terrain le quotidien de
ceux qui n'ont pas voulu se faire
vacciner qui tourne au casse-tête
parfois certains sont même contraints
d'arrêter leurs activités ne comprennent
pas pourquoi on ne leur permet pas
d'emprunter un autre chemin le reportage
est signée guillemard aussi avec à
julien guitare je suis à chambry une
petite ville à côté de laon dans l'aisne
et je suis ici pour rencontrer une
orthophoniste au 16 septembre au
lendemain de l'obligation vaccinale elle
a cessé son activité et elle va nous
raconter pourquoi
bonjour marie clothilde merci de nous
recevoir lors on est ici devant votre
cabinet qui n'accueille plus aucun
passion depuis près d'un mois maintenant
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi bonjour
écoutez c'est à cause de l'obligation
vaccinale à laquelle je ne veux pas me
soumettre mes entrées je vais vous
expliquer tout ça
quand est ce qu'ils font tous ses
enfants tous ces adultes maintenant que
vous n'exercez plus alors pour les
enfants autistes c'est vraiment très
compliqué puisque à distance je ne peux
pas vraiment les aider et puis c'est
vraiment très spécifiques comme
rééducation par contre pour les enfants
de maternelle qui ont des retards de
paroles ou des difficultés
d'articulation et puis aussi pour les
enfants qui ont des difficultés dans
l'apprentissage de la lecture je donne
accès aux parents en fait mes vidéos
didactiques donc j'ai une chaîne youtube
qui s'appelle ortho astuces que j'avais
déjà créé depuis quelques années face à
la liste d'attentes qui est considérable
chez nous on était très étonné parce que
l'on pensait pouvoir faire de la télé
orthophonie
puisqu'au premier confinement on a eu le
droit de faire de la télé orthophonie et
là on nous dit non il faut absolument
vous faire vacciner donc là je ne
comprends pas
qu est ce qui fait qu est ce qui a
motivé cet choix de ne pas vous faire
vacciner exactement donc c'est déjà une
confiance qui a été rompu en décembre
2020 donc par rapport à la politique
sanitaire quand le gouvernement n'a pas
enlevé les masques pour les enfants à
l'école ensuite les critères à chaque
fois pour décider les mesures changent
et on ne sait plus à quel saint se vouer
je ne peux pas avoir confiance en un en
un vaccin qui est encore à mêmes
conditionnelle et puis pour lequel on
n'a pas suffisamment de recul maintenant
on nous dit qu'il faut une troisième
dose l'efficacité n'a pas l'air non plus
absolu on sait qu'on peut contaminer
encore les autres personnes en étant
vacciner donc pourquoi m'obliger à faire
un vaccin si je peux toujours contaminé
les enfants que je côtoie je préfère
faire un test pcr tous les trois jours
si on est dans un examen médical et si
dans cette région oui tout à fait nos
médecins partent progressivement tous à
la retraite on a un peu de personnes qui
s'installent à nouveau dans la région ça
fait 23 ans que j'exerce ici quand j'ai
commencé je n'avais pas de listes
d'attentes déjà et au fur et à mesure on
a une liste d'attentes qui s'agrandit un
an deux ans d'attentes on ne peut même
plus dire le délai en fait aux personnes
actuellement
on est avec votre fils pierre lys c'est
ça à qui donc vous fait l'école à la
maison racontez nous un petit peu
pourquoi pour sa décision de faire
l'école à la maison à votre fils mon
combat contre le masque à l'école pour
les enfants puisque je fais partie de
plusieurs collectifs notamment collectif
de parents collectif de pédiatres et un
collectif d'orthophonistes dernièrement
on avait signé un manifeste de plus de
100 au faux nist qui témoignaient des
difficultés d'apprentissage que pourrait
avoir l'enfant donc à cause de ce masque
à l'école en juin
quand j'ai découvert en fait que le
masque n'était pas enlever aux enfants
malgré le fait que l'épidémie baissé et
qu'on trouverait tout rond rouvray les
restaurants et cetera j'ai décidé donc
de faire l'école à la maison et de
retirer mon enfant du système scolaire
qu'est ce que vous avez comme comme une
solution interne j'espère que je vais
pouvoir reprendre mon activité
d'orthophonistes tout en n'étant pas
vacciner sinon et sinon eh bien il
faudra se reconvertir puisque je ne
souhaite pas me
soumettre à cette obligation
jamais je ne peux pas dire jamais ou
alors le retour des tests pc soit à
nouveau mais bon ça avec un certain coût
du jour même oui alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup de je pense de
professionnels de santé qui seraient
prêts
à payer 1 les tests pcr et allait
rentrer dans nos charges ans c'est tout
à fait possible et je pense que moi je
serais tout à fait d'accord pour faire
cela et on vient d'entendre donc
marie-clotilde qui fait partie de ces
résistants de la dernière heure face à
la stratégie sanitaire du gouvernement
du côté de l'exécutif on laisse entendre
que la troisième dose pourrait donc
finir par devenir obligatoire si l'on
veut garder son passé ni terre alors la
troisième dose la dose de trop on attend
vos réactions sur le conte télégramme
verte et france ils sont déjà très
nombreuses et c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soit
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler rudyard des six
avocats spécialisés dans le droit pénal
médical vous défendent également en ce
moment entre autres à une employée
d'hôpital qui refusent de se faire
vacciner bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés bruno mais garman un chef du
service d'animation l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris bonsoir docteur
merci également à vous d'être là
beaucoup de réaction ce soir c'est un
sujet qui évidemment fait toujours
parler qui est clivant 1 on s'en est
déjà rendu compte sur ce plateau n'est
ce pas docteur mais germann on va
d'ailleurs tout de suite commencer par
ce commentaire un des railleries de
noter des spectateurs ce soir cette
réaction de stéphanie notre chef
gouvernement va peut-être proposer une
carte de fidélité à la 8ème dose et bien
il ya des bons pour aller au restaurant
message également de david healy a déjà
deux doses de trop entre l'obligation
vaccinale pour certaines professions et
la vaccination forcée via le pass
sanitaire ce gouvernement on a déjà trop
fait petite colère chez les
téléspectateurs
qui ont réagi regardez 6 en prolongeant
le pass and i ter jusqu'à l'été est ce
que justement le gouvernement va trop
loin
à mon sens il faut un moment donné à
arrêter toutes les mesures que l'on
prend chez le sentiment mais c'est un
sentiment personnel au début de la crise
en mars 2020 on n'avait pas suffisamment
appréhender l'ampleur du désastre qui
allait tomber sur la france et puis
aujourd'hui pour essayer de récupérer un
tout petit peu une situation qui a été
réellement dramatique parce qu'il faut
comprendre que les gens ne veulent plus
de cette situation de confinement de
d'enfermement de cessation d'activité
est bon on prend des mesures peut-être
aujourd'hui disproportionnée par rapport
à la réalité la réalité clinique sur le
terrain et
alors vous dire mais c'est un petit peu
voilà qui a été coupée j'en profite pour
faire revenir renault mégane et les
mesures doctor death proportionnée pour
vous est également qu'ils ne sont plus
justifiés si on suit l'idée de rudyard
v6
alors j'ai été abandonné par mais mes
deux invités bruno meyer ban voilà je
suis content de voir qu'on vous a
récupéré
des mesures peut-être disproportionnée
c'est ce que nous explique l instant
rudy rb6 mais c'est aussi un sentiment
qu'ont beaucoup de français aujourd'hui
on tire trop sur la corde ou s'est
justifié selon vous
alors je suis désolé effectivement la
collection la très bonne
je n'entends pas très bien les questions
malgré tout il faut savoir que le schéma
de vaccination
ne relève pas d'une décision politique
ou d'un choix d'un gouvernement d'un
ministre de la santé de ce sont les
études scientifiques
ce sont les données médicales
qui décide si un vaccin doit être
administré en deux trois ou quatre dos
et s'il faut faire des rappels et à quel
rythme
c'est vrai qu'avec la qu'ovide nous
découvrons le schéma vaccinal au en même
temps que nous vaccinons les individus
et que nous voyons évidemment
la réponse que nous analysons la réponse
immunitaire à cette vaccination c'est là
où il y a on va dire une certaine
incompréhension de la population
mais il faut le dire ça n'est pas une
décision politique
le choix de faire une troisième dose ou
un rappel relève des données
observationnelles qui montre que les
anticorps neutralisants acquis à la
suite de la vaccination se réduisent
avec le temps se réduisent de façon
significative au delà du 6e mois et
pourrait ne pas être suffisant pour
protéger les personnes les plus âgées et
les personnes à risque regardez 6
d'accord avec cette analyse ce n'est pas
une décision politique ne décidé
d'administrer une une vaccination mais
c'est peut-être une décision politique
de la conditionner opa sanitaires
liés au téléphone
on vous entend on à votre image et c'est
bien on a on à votre sont alors on va
faire avec effectivement eh bien je vais
vous donner quelques indications portées
eu la semaine dernière
semble aller millions l'année dernière
les files indiqué qu'il y avait 50 morts
par jour
on en est actuellement à 15 nord parjure
quand le conseil d'état a statué sur le
passé ni terre en mai 2021 il évaluer le
nombre de personnes qui étaient conçus
voilà on a de nouveau perdu décidément
volière baissier ça va être compliqué
mais nous excuser en tout cas pour pour
ses problèmes de connexion ce soir on va
essayer d'aller un peu plus loin
et si besoin en malheureusement
d'interrompre à ce débat bruno merga
vannes avant de vous faire réagir à
nouveau gendre et justement vous faire
écouter jean castex dans le prolongement
de ce que vous nous disiez ce sont les
autorités médicales qui choisissent
écouter jean castex était lundi dernier
depuis le vatican
les conditions pour bénéficier du pass
sont fixés par la haute autorité de
santé à la haute autorité de santé de
nous dire si nous devons ou non étendre
l'éligibilité du pass à la troisième
dose la vie est sollicité hong renault
mégane évidemment c'est ça qui me le feu
aux poudres parce qu'elle est les anti
vaccin dès le début voilà qu'on aura
peut-être du mal à convaincre de votre
point de vue mais il ya aussi ceux qui
ont peut-être joué le jeu eux qui ont
fait leurs deux doses wallace agents
pour eux mais aussi pour une immunité
collective cette idée d'une troisième
dose est ce que ce n'est pas jean
revient à l'objet de trèbes des balados
de trop
non je ne crois pas à vous voyez un
certain nombre de vaccins pour obtenir
et avoir la garantie d'une protection
nécessite plusieurs doses et d injection
de rappel le vaccin contre le tétanos et
bien on en reçoit trois doses au moment
de la naissance puis une première dose
de rappel un an puis tous les cinq ans
puis tous les dix ans donc vous voyez
que le schéma de vaccination dépend du
mode d'action du vaccin et lorsque le
vaccin est dit inerte c'est à dire ne
contient pas un virus inactivé c'est le
cas par exemple des vaccins contre lacko
vide eh bien il faut faire des rappels
relativement répéter voyez quand on
prend un antibiotique pour traiter une
infection bactérienne et bien on ne
conteste pas la durée de
l'antibiothérapie celle-ci peut-être en
une seule dose pour tel type de microbes
et elle peut être sur plusieurs jours
parfois plusieurs mois pour tel autre
type de bactéries donc ce sont les
données scientifiques
bien entendu j'ai entendu votre idée
mais on a le sentiment
que ça ne va pas s'arrêter et ne pas
avoir de visibilité sur les vaccins que
vous nous citer là on a une connaissance
aussi car on sait qu'il ya un calendrier
vaccinal qui est préétabli là on se dit
ça ne va jamais s'arrêter
alors vous avez raison dans le coup en
tout cas pour le moment il est
recommandé de faire une troisième doses
pour une population à très haut risque
de faire des formes graves
lorsque l'immunité des croix c'est le
cas des personnes de plus de 65 ans des
personnes avec comorbidités nous
espérons tous évidemment que peut-être
cette dose de rappel sera suffisante
pour renforcer de façon massive
l'immunité et éviter de nouvelles doses
maintenant nous ne sommes pas à l'abri
de l'apparition de nouveaux variants et
que l'immunité au final ne soit pas
suffisante et qu'il faille à nouveau
recourir à des rappels il faut savoir
qu'en parallèle la recherche progresse
et que on essaie de mettre au point des
vaccins plus efficaces avec une durée de
réponse plus importante et qu'ils
puissent évidemment donner une immunité
face à tout type de variants y compris
les variants qui ne sont toujours pas
apparu regard mais si l'on vous a
récupéré je vais vous laisser agir sur
ce qui s'est dit en espérant vous ayez
pu suivre un petit peu les les
développements c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de levée de boucliers
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle donc on
crie à une atteinte aux libertés
publiques on enjambe la présidentielle
donc la question est est ce que pour
vous tout cela et et politique le
docteur nous disait d'instants l'on sait
médical et ses dictées par une situation
qu'ils imposent sanitaire donc
il ya des chiffres qui parlent son
compte on sait que d'avoir une double
immunité l'immunité vaccinale et tout le
monde en est d'accord et il n'immunise
est aussi personnel biologique et ça il
faut faire comme quand même confiance au
corps humain maintenant qu' il y ait une
troisième dose qu'ils soient
éventuellement proposer à des personnes
qui ont des comorbidités qui sont des
personnes âgées qui sont des personnes
fragiles je crois que là tu le débat n'a
pas lieu tout le monde est pratiquement
d'accord là où on trouve qu'il y a des
limites qui ont été dépassés c'est quand
on impose le vaccin à certaines
personnes et pas à d'autres quand on
importe du vaccin à des enfants âgés de
moins de 12 ans et quand on impose à
toute la population dépasse sanitaires
voyez l'exemple des pays nordiques que
ce soit la hollande le danemark la suède
le une ouverture a été créé je pense que
quelque part il faut redonner cette
liberté aux citoyens viennent entendu
sous le contrôle des chiffres qui nous
seront transmis semaine après semaine
bien entendu il nous faut pas
regarder c'est ce qui me va décidément
quittait définitivement merci en tout
cas bruno mais regarde maintenant la
ronde a compris en tout cas le vos
messages respectifs merci d'avoir été
avec nous et veuillez nous excuser
encore pour cette connexion approximatif
ce soir merci à vous et la crise
sanitaire ailleurs en europe de
projecteur ce soir sur la situation
notamment au royaume uni qui fait face à
la propagation d'un sou variant du très
contagieux delta les contaminations
explose les autorités de santé demande
aux gouvernements de durcir les mesures
de lutte contre le coc vide et ménat
bnda
c'est l'effervescence ce mercredi à
londres ils sont des dizaines et exprimé
leur scepticisme quant à la propagation
du colis de 19 alors qu'au même moment
le sou variant du très contagieux delta
le variant à y 4.2 progresse au royaume
uni du côté des professionnels de santé
l'inquiétude est à son comble nous
sommes déjà loin d'atteindre nos
objectifs en matière de délais
d'attentes notamment de délais d'attenté
aux urgences pour les ambulances bien
sûr et pour les listes d'attentes
elle-même elle nous sommes donc loin
d'atteindre ses objectifs actuellement
cela a des conséquences sur la sécurité
des patients et ça ne va qu'empirer donc
le gouvernement doit tenir ses promesses
et en particulier ses promesses et
d'essayer d'éviter aux services publics
de santé d'être submergés et c'est ce
dont nous avons besoin agir maintenant
afin d'éviter cela et si nous ne le
faisons pas j'ai bien peur qu une fois
de plus et nous sommes déjà passés par
là nous nous enfoncions dans une crise
le royaume uni compte quarante mille
nouveaux cas d'infection au co vie de 19
par jour avec un taux d'incidence bien
plus élevé que dans le reste de l'europe
pour certains scientifiques
cette explosion des nouveaux cas
concernent surtout les jeunes peu de
mineurs et en vacciner mais aussi les
plus âgés vaccinés très tôt dont
l'immunité est en baisse comme elle peut
être imputé à lapproche néo libérale du
gouvernement dans sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
une approche que down in the streets
n'est pas près de changer
nous examinons attentivement les données
et nous nous mettrons pas en oeuvre
notre plan b de mesures d'urgence à ce
stade mais nous resterons vigilants nous
nous préparons à toutes les éventualités
tout en renforçant nos défenses vital
qui peuvent nous aider à lutter contre
le virus
depuis le début de la pandémie le
royaume uni a déploré cent trente neuf
mille morts liées aux commodities 9
alors se dirige-t-on vers de nouvelles
restrictions au royaume uni pour contrer
la propagation du colis pour en parler
nous sommes en direct de basso au
royaume uni avec bharat par camion
expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
soit barad pangkhan hier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france les
nouvelles continues est de contamination
donc un parmi les plus importantes
d'europe qui approchent leur niveau de
la violente vague de l'hiver dernier
comment vous en tout cas vous vous
l'expliquer
et nissan
personnes très occupées à mi temps est
venu je ressens de l'embarras
le taux de contamination est parmi les
plus hauts du mej et c'est vraiment une
honte pour une nation aussi riche aussi
intelligente que la nôtre nous ne
traitons pas le problème correctement
pricée c'est vraiment embarrassant et
c'est là que nous en trouvons quand vous
dites nous ne traitons pas le problème
correctement je reviens donc à ma
question c'est parce que on donc les
politiques peut-être ne le traite pas
correctement qui lie à cette
multiplication des propagations
expliquez-nous
se pose
je pense quand même source en soulignant
les politiques qui échappe au
lactose et nous pouvons gérer les
situations une infection évident encore
une trace en réduisant le constat du
gers en
utilisant
imposant et le port du masque il met en
place des mesures de vente ou là sur les
lieux
les politiques ont décelé ne soyez pas
nécessaire et nous voyons maintenant les
conséquences aujourd'hui clairement les
scientifiques demandent davantage de
fermeté aux autorités c'est bien cela ce
n'est qu'à ce prix là que vous vous en
sortirez
goodchoice
annuler
la dernière ajoute m alors qu'il
faudrait mettre en place des mesures de
précaution maintenant il s'excuse à
temps leur
côté
des précautions à l'avenir en vue de
l'hiver nous devons également nous
assurer que les écoles
contre le coronavirus et contre la
grippe et le problème là s'agissant de
la vaccination des enfants et c'est que
c'est qu'elle ralentit nous devions rex
mais les adultes ce peintre l'abri mais
cela doit s'ajouter également à toutes
les autres mesures mentionnées le port
du masque de bonne qualité c'est à dire
des masques
ffp2 par les nouveaux variants sont plus
contaminant donc ce sont des mesures
simples qu'il faut appliquer la banque
aignan ne vous entends pas parler de la
vaccination pourtant le royaume uni a
été l'un des meilleurs au monde sur ce
point la campagne a été lancée à ses
taux alors justement ceci explique
peut-être cela c'était trop tôt il ya
peu d'immunité comment on explique
justement ce regain alors que la
vaccination elle est plutôt un succès
chez vous
so i mean programme
d'immunisation de vaccination royaume
uni a commencé tôt et a bien marché
les pays de l'union européenne nous ont
rattrapés et nous ont même dépassé
mais
la rive peut-être et c'est intéressant
dont nous le suivrons de très près
c'est que peut-être après environ six
mois où l'humidité chez les personnes
vulnérables c'est-à-dire les personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des comores
de boue s'est donc limitée commença à
diminuer lentement et est dans une
situation ils sont
confrontés à un nombre de virus
important la contamination reprend car
l'immunité naturelle environ six mois on
pourrait peut-être défendre cette thèse
pour ces personnes en particulier et
nous recommandons donc tu es dose de
rappel pour ces personnes ok donc
troisième dose recommandée en tout cas
pour l'autre scientifique que vous aide
si j'ai bien compris au royaume uni
également on a parlé tout à l'heure de
ce nouveau variant qu'est ce qu'on sait
de lui précisément qui est apparue donc
au royaume uni
nous l'appelons le variante delta pu
souffler 4.2 pour accepter un petit
changement dans l as
oublié apparemment cela pourrait être
un variant 10% plus contaminant que le
variant delta muse et la bonne nouvelle
c'est que les ornements des is cause il
ne pousse pas d'essence plus grave de la
maladie comme une autre bonne nouvelle
pour les maisons by passel c'est acquis
mais ne rend pas efficaces les actions
de so we have any donc nous nous
trouvons face à un nouveau variant
d'intérêt ne voulait surveillons de près
la fumée il n'est pas inhabituel une
époque extraordinaire pour le moment en
tout cas avec les informations dont nous
disposons une dernière petite question
baraquements kenya on en parlait en
début de ce journal l'assemblée qui veut
voter aujourd'hui en france qui votent
en tout cas sur la prolongation de ce
pass sanitaires pour accéder à tous les
endroits de loisirs au cinéma ou au
restaurant entre autres qu'en est il
chez vous au royaume uni de ce pass
sanitaire est ce que c'est une curiosité
française on sait la même chose chez
vous
êtes nommé louis de notre maximum en
nous n'avons pas mis en place toute la
sport vaccinale et nous n'envisageons
pas cette solution pour le moment
je pense personnellement qu'un
passe-temps fax n'est pas nécessaire les
yeux car avec une dit qu'une seule chose
est mieux rudy que la personne non est
immunisée mais elle ne dit pas si la
personne est contaminée au sont à 90 il
faut se rappeler que même si on a été
seulement vaccinés les l'est toujours
que s'il est attrapé la maladie et
devant transmettre
ma question est la suivante quel est
l'objectif de ce passeport vaccinale
apparaît bien sûr d'eux de montrer que
l'on est bien vaccinés merci beaucoup
baratta pour gagner d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce soir
et ailleurs dans le monde la crise
sanitaire qui pourrait coûter cher au
président brésilien une commission d'
enquête parlementaire demande
aujourd'hui d'inculpation de jaillir bol
sonar où il fait l'objet le 10 chefs
d'accusation pour sa gestion de
l'épidémie le président est notamment
accusé de crimes contre l'humanité pour
sa politique durant cette crise ce soir
il se défend il déclare être coupable
d'absolument rien il fait partie d'une
longue liste d'une soixantaine de
personnes auditionnées ces six derniers
mois
cette procédure des sénateurs pour
obtenir leur inculpation en tout cas
très peu de chances d'aboutir on le
rappelle le candidat tué plus de six
cent mille personnes au brésil
et autre pays autre situation sanitaire
la russie fasse un nouveau triste record
de décès quotidiens et plus de 1000
morts liés aux qu'ovide 19 ces dernières
24 heures du jamais vu jusqu'ici les
limites poutine qui vient de décréter
une semaine chômé pour enrayer les sorts
de l'épidémie en fait le point avec
notre correspondante mejlis destrait
face à l'aggravation de la situation
épidémiologique observée depuis
plusieurs semaines en russie vladimir
poutine a annoncé qu'il soutenait la
proposition du gouvernement russe
d'instaurer une semaine chômé à
l'échelle du pays cette période pourra
être prolongé dans les régions où la
situation ne s'améliore aurait pas
écouté il faut casser le pic des
nouvelles
zinfos vague d'infection
et donc il ya des mesures de soutien qui
sont protégés qui sont proposés chers
collègues et je pense qu évidemment
les congés exceptionnels qui sont
proposés avec maintien du salaire
doivent être adoptées le chef d'état a
appelé les citoyens à rester chez eux
dans le cas où un membre de leur famille
contracterait le virus et les régions à
contrôler le confinement de ses citoyens
avec tact et respect plein dit mi-août
il regrette par ailleurs le taux de
vaccination insuffisant dans le pays
alors que celui ci possède d'après lui
le meilleur vaccin au monde écoutez et
encore une fois je tiens à le dire y a
que deux moyens
soit être malade sans même soit se faire
vacciner mais il vaut mieux se faire
vacciner
puisque les conséquences de cette
maladie son bourdon prenez cette
responsabilité
prenez toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour vous protéger pour protéger votre
santé vos proches ou rappelons que la
russie a enregistré ce mercredi 1028
nouveaux décès dus aux coronavirus un
record depuis le début de la pandémie le
nombre de nouveaux cas de contamination
s'élève quant à lui à plus de 34000
on reste en russie où se tiennent en ce
moment des discussions internationales
sur le cas afghan une délégation de
talibans et à moscou avec des
représentants d'une dizaine de pays dont
la chine l'inde les dires en réunion
pour organiser un pont humanitaire vers
kaboul notamment mais également pour
rappeler aux talibans qui doivent tenir
leurs engagements et précision de
verhaeghe hoffman à moscou
la communauté internationale doit
revenir sur ses préjugés et se joindre
aux efforts mis en oeuvre pour aider
l'afghanistan sinon ils vont pénaliser
le peuple afghan a déclaré l'envoyé
spécial et russes pour l'afghanistan
samir kaboul off aller sur des
consultations organisées à moscou la
question de la reconnaissance du nouveau
pouvoir afghan a été également abordée
selon amir cabo love cette
reconnaissance sera envisageable lorsque
l'hôte éléments respecteront leurs
engagements envers la communauté
internationale et surtout leurs propres
aux populations je vous propose
d'écouter
certainement elle a été soulevée comment
ne pas la soulever mais tout le monde du
moins notre ministre des affaires
étrangères l'a indiqué sans aucun doute
ce moment viendra un jour
viendra et tout le monde l'a dit à la
délégation afghane quand ils
commenceront à répondre à la plupart des
attentes de la communauté internationale
attentes qui sont liées à des questions
de droits de l'homme et d'inclusion
de son côté la délégation des talibans
se dit satisfait des résultats des
pourparlers à moscou le ministre de
l'information du nouveau gouvernement
afghan a partagé avec art et ses
impressions dans une interview exclusive
écoutez
c'était une bonne réunion nous avons
atteint un bon résultat nous pensons que
nous allons participer à d'autres
négociations et il y en aura d'autres
donc comme je l ai déjà dit c'était une
rencontre fructueuse avec un résultat
positif c'était une grande réunion
impliquant d'autres pays ce qui est une
très bonne chose
j'espère qu'à l'avenir il y aura
d'autres réunions comme celle ci et que
l'on va régler les problèmes par la voie
de la négociation
plus tôt dans la journée lors de
l'ouverture du forum le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov a
souligné qu'il n'existait pas
d'alternance crédible pouvoir en place
actuellement à kaboul sergey lavrov a
également confirmé que la russie
continuerait à coopérer avec l'émirat
islamique d'afghanistan et a promis
l'envoi d'aidé humanitaire pour la
population tout en appelant la
communauté internationale en faire de
même
pour en parler nous sommes avec olivier
crown ancien officier en afghanistan son
conseiller politique à kaboul également
bonsoir olivier kohn merci d'être avec
nous la russie 1 qui reconnaît donc et
les efforts je citant des talibans pour
stabiliser l'afghanistan vous
connaissent évidemment bien ce terrain
c'est le cas stabiliser l'afghanistan
ils le font les talibans aujourd'hui
alors cessé alors déjà l'enjeu de ce
sommet un cake est colossal en réalité
j'ai presque envie de dire qui est
encore plus stratégique que le sommet
qui a eu lieu il ya quinze jours en
italie le sommet g20 où il était
question principalement de deux
questions humanitaires cette fois ci ce
sommet l'enjeu est énorme que vient
chercher les talibans un les talibans
ils viennent chercher la reconnaissance
internationale tout simplement qu'ils
n'ont pas à l'heure actuelle les pays
qui étaient présents donc au sommet qui
sont essentiellement des pays de la
région dont des puissances régionales
cherchent à avoir un afghanistan
maintenant qui est stable et qui ils
veulent tout simplement que
l'afghanistan ne redevienne pas un
sanctuaire pour le terrorisme djihadiste
international
c'est ça dont il s'agit c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce sommet donc je dirais pour
répondre à votre question concernant les
talibans est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
stabiliser le pays les gens répondent
que c'est un petit peu l'arroseur arrosé
dans quelque part parce que ces vingt
dernières années c'étaient les talibans
qui était dans la lutte armée
l'insurrection qui posait les bombes aux
quatre coins l'afghanistan quatre coins
du pays maintenant ils sont ils ont
atteint leur objectif qui était de
prendre le pouvoir et donc il se
retrouve à devoir contrôler le pays et
est maintenant c'est qu'ils font face à
j'ai envie de dire à pire que c'est à
dire à la branche locale la branche
afghane de l'état islamique s'attelle
voilà qui s'appelle état islamique or la
salle et qui maintenant à son tour
posent des bombes aux quatre coins du
pays envoient des kamikazes se faire
sauter à kaboul et c'est ce que faisait
des talibans un an maintenant les deux
organisations sont sont opposés son
rival mais dans ce sens là finalement
l'état islamique avec des objectifs qui
sont une stratégie qui est différente
mais il remplace ils prennent un petit
peu le rôle qu'avait al qaïda à l'époque
en fait c'est à dire d'une espèce de
complot de jill le djihad international
donc ça veut dire si on vous suit bien
olivier crown que d'une certaine manière
il ya une forme de pragmatisme pays qui
se réunissent aujourd'hui qui saigne
certains efforts des talibans parce que
tout simplement il n'y a pas le choix
les etats unis sont partie l'occident
avec aujourd'hui bien il faut traiter
avec ceux qui tentent en tout cas de
tenir le pays contre des nouveaux
méchants si j'ose dire peut-être encore
plus méchant ou également méchant enfin
voila vous venez de le dire il n'y a pas
le choix c'est à dire il faut composer
avec ceux qui sont au pouvoir la barre
etc les talibans que nous combattu
pendant vingt ans avec le résultat qu'on
connaît tous maintenant ils sont au
pouvoir et eux mêmes n'ont pas intérêt à
ce que l'afghanistan le pays qui
contrôlent leur pays devienne un havre
de terrorisme international ou
ressemblent dans la guerre quoi guerre
civile internationale ceci dit c'est pas
dans leur intérêt donc maintenant leur
intérêt à eux c'est de contrôler le pays
donc à eux maintenant de faire le boulot
et les pays qui sont autour les pays
régionaux n'ont pas du tout envie de
voir se développer comme je disais
semblait des cellules de l'état
islamique parce que l'état islamique est
composé de djihadistes internationaux
donc il ya des ouïgours il ya des
ouzbeks et des afghans bien évidemment
il ya les pakistanais enfin ça vient un
peu de tous les coins du monde quoi
beaucoup de la région
exactement c'est un peu la logique et la
crainte de toutes ces puissances
régionales donc tout le monde ceux
prévus prémunir que ce soit
l'ouzbékistan les pays frontaliers
évidemment l'ouzbékistan le tadjikistan
la chine bien sûr parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de ouïgours volontaires
ouïghours qui sont qui viennent faire le
djihad labassa sais c'est pas quelque
chose de récent ce pas un phénomène
nouveau et ça fait depuis un moment mais
toujours est il qu'ils rejoignent
typiquement des organisations une
organisation comme l'état islamique
rollason donc ça voilà donc ces pays là
la russie bien entendu parce que son
flanc sud les ex républiques soviétiques
donc sont directement s'ils voulaient
confrontés au problème donc c'est dans
l'intérêt je dirais de tous les pays
réunis autour du sommet d'avoir un pays
stable où il n'y a pas de pas
d'implantation soul et de l'état
islamique dont cet aliment maintenant
contrôler le pays en son pouvoir de
faire le boulot quoi on sait plusieurs
puissances ont cassé des dents en
afghanistan
les occidentaux ont récemment les
américains il ya eu les soviétiques un
peu plus tôt est ce que les talibans
sont en mesure de tenir ce pays
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils en ont le
pouvoir et des moyens en tout cas c'est
un pays qui connaissent pour avoir été
eux mêmes dans la guérilla pendant 20
ans donc ils connaissent tous les coins
et tous les cailloux du pays j'ai envie
de dire ils connaissent les méthodes
parce que c'est celle qu'ils ont
pratiqué le même c'est-à-dire due à la
fois des de l'intrigué de la lutte armée
de la guérilla de la guerre irrégulière
et puis du terrorisme les talibans après
pratiquer sa grande échelle dans le pays
maintenant ils doivent ils sont
confrontés à la même logique
ils ont des armes enfin c'est pas ça qui
réellement ça apporte un plus un dvi
culte des armes etc ils ont récupéré
tous cas ce qu'a laissé derrière l'armée
afghane qui a déserté maintenant si vous
voulez c'est surtout qui se sera
probablement pas les mêmes méthodes ils
seront moins regardants sur les droits
de l'homme je dirais qu'ils n'ont pas se
mettre tout un tas de contraintes pour
arriver à l'objectif un cif ce sera
beaucoup plus répressif et ça sera pas
dans le pas dans le cadre des droits de
l'homme ça certainement ça se passera
pas comme ça et justement ces droits de
l'homme ça sera ma dernière question
dont parle beaucoup l'onu les
occidentaux mais aussi quand même ces
pays en ce moment en russie c'est un
combat perdu d'avancé
voilà donc vouloir faire plier les
talibans sur ce point c'est évidemment
que ce sont des valeurs et des critères
que tout le monde annonce pas seulement
les occidentaux la russie et la chine
enfin tous les pays il avance c'est
important l'inclusivité et je veux dire
le président poutine on a parlé enfin
avoir un gouvernement qui est inclusif
c'est-à-dire qui inclut pas seulement
des pachtouns n est elle pas seulement
des talibans et des pachtouns mais aussi
toute la diversité ethnique du pays plus
des femmes donc c'est un critère que
tout le monde avance comme les droits et
les droits de l'homme bien sûr
maintenant
si vous voulez c'est peut-être pas la
question qui est bien qui vient au rosso
en haut de la liste je dirais c'est
vraiment les questions sécuritaires qui
compte le plus accessoirement bien sûr
tout le monde veut que les droits de
l'homme soient respectés ce serait bien
ce serait un monde idéal quoi où les
taliban respecter les droits de l'homme
et ses quelque part aussi dans leur
intérêt en fin de compte parce que s'ils
cherchent cette reconnaissance
internationale et c'est ce qu'ils sont
venus chercher à moscou aujourd'hui la
reconnaissance internationale bon un
moment donné il va bien falloir qu'ils
se plient un certain nombre de règles à
peu près à plus ou moins comme une fois
merci beaucoup nous avons apporté votre
merci à vous et la russie qui espère
donc un que les talibans seront en
mesure de l'expliquer de vaincre des
sondes ganis ton le groupe terroriste
qui déstabilise encore et toujours la
syrie le penny meurtrier en corse et
dernière heure par heure des attaques un
bus militaire a été visé ce matin par un
attentat à la bombe à damas quatorze
personnes ont été tuées est en train n'a
pas été revendiquée peu après des
bombardements de l'armée ont fait 13
morts dont 10 civils dans la province
d'idlib les explications de juliette
lamy avec marion caudal
6h45 heure locale un bus militaire est
pris pour cible deux engins explosifs
attachés aux bus ont provoqué une
violente déflagration
je dormais quand j'ai entendu une forte
explosion je me suis réveillée et j'ai
vu un bus en feu qui s'est ensuite
arrêté après avoir heurté le trottoir
j'ai ensuite entendu le bruit d'une
deuxième explosion mais celle ci n'était
pas aussi forte que la première
un troisième engin explosif a été
découvert et désarmé dans la même zone
[Musique]
j'ai entendu une forte explosion près de
moi au début je ne savais pas d'où elle
venait mais en regardant de plus près
j'ai vu qu'un bus transportant des
soldats étaient visés cela faisait
longtemps que quelque chose de semblable
n'était pas arrivé j'espère que cette
explosion sera la dernière
[Musique]
un
attentat à la bombe considéré comme le
plus meurtrier dans la capitale depuis
2010 est le 15 mars 32 personnes avaient
perdu la vie dans deux attentats
kamikazes simultanée aux abords du
palais de justice une troisième bombe
avaient également été trouvés dans le
périmètre puis démantelés par les forces
de sécurité syriennes quelques jours
plus tard l'attaqué avait été
revendiquée par l'état islamique
depuis 2018 les forces du président
bachar al assad contrôlent la majeure
partie de la syrie ainsi damas avait été
en grande partie épargné par les
violences des dernières années notamment
depuis la reprise par l'armée du dernier
gros bastion rebelle et autres pays
plongé dans l'instabilité et la libye il
ya dix ans jour pour jour avait lieu la
chip chute du dictateur kadhafi après
quatre décennies au pouvoir des
commémorations était organisée
aujourd'hui par ses sympathisants ils
ont dénoncé je cite les crimes de guerre
commis par l'otan alors que l'élection
présidentielle approche à grands pas
yamina le rwanda avec farah mais qu' un
parfum de nostalgie plane au dessus de
bani walid
cette petite ville de 100000 habitants
située à l'ouest de la libye est le fief
de la tribu des warfalla fidèles au
dirigeant déchu en 2011 dix ans après sa
mort il regrette encore leur ancien
dirigeant mouammar kadhafi
c'est pourtant à cet homme que d'autres
reprochaient une implacable répression
de toute velléité contestataire
notamment pendant la révolution du
printemps arabe
la raison pour laquelle nous les
habitants de bani walid et d'autres
villes de la libye sommes restés
attachés à l'ancien régime puisque nous
sommes restés attachés à l'ancien régime
c'est que les événements de février 2011
n'ont apporté que guerre désolation
division est atteinte à la souveraineté
de notre pays
pour ses fidèles la chute du colonel n'a
été possible que grâce aux frappes
aériennes franco britannique et à la
trahison d'une partie de l'armée et ils
en sont certains c'est un symbole
international
voulu abattre
mouammar kadhafi est un symbole pour
tous les peuples libres du monde son
influence aller au delà de la libye ses
admirateurs et ses partisans sont
partout dans le monde
du point de vue de ses partisans la mort
de kadhafi a ouvert la porte à de
multiples ingérences étrangères ce pays
d'afrique du nord est devenue le théâtre
d'affrontements entre puissances
extérieures qui a encouragé les libyens
à se déchirer depuis 2014 la libye était
divisée en deux autorités qui se
livraient une querelle de légitimité
avec d'un côté les soutiens à fayet zèle
sa rage à tripoli et de l'autre le
maréchal haftar à benghazi une guerre
civile qui sera interrompue par un
cessez le feu instauré en octobre 2020
un gouvernement de transition a été mis
en place en mars dernier sous l'égide de
l'onu pour mener le pays vers une
élection présidentielle prévue le 24
décembre
pour l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
cette solution n'apportera pas la paix
certaines personnalités politiques ne
veulent pas de l'élection car elle
menace leurs intérêts personnels
d'autres s'inquiètent de les voir porter
au pouvoir un personnage
inapproprié issus de l'ancien régime au
dollar mais il y aura certainement un
conflit politique et une forte
polarisation qui peut se transformer en
conflit armé
avant la révolution de février 2011 les
libyens ont connu une certaine
prospérité notamment grâce à une
formidable manne pétrolière un temps
révolu car la production a nettement
diminué un constat identique pour le pib
du pays qui a frôlé les 75 milliards de
dollars en 2010 pour atteindre les 52
milliards en 2019
la direction maintenant les états unis
après des jours de controverse la
compagnie aérienne américaine southwest
airlines a finalement renoncé à des
mesures punitives pour ses salariés non
vaccinés on en parle avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomas et c'est donc un
retournement de situation saluée comme
une victoire par ceux qui militent
contre l'obligation vaccinale
oui la compagnie aérienne southwest
airlines a finalement décidé de renoncer
a placé en congé sans solde les salariés
qui ne seront pas vaccinés d'ici la date
butoir du 8 décembre prochain à la place
les employés en question devront
présenter un minima une preuve qu'ils
ont ont demandé une procédure
d'exemption pour des motifs des motifs
médicaux ou religieux et puis ensuite
ils devront se conformer aux règles
sanitaires en vigueur dans l'entreprise
notamment avec le port du masque alors
ces derniers jours cette compagnie
aérienne était devenu un symbole pour
les opposants aux obligations de
vaccination il y avait même eu même eu
des manifestations comme ici à dallas je
vous propose d'écouter quelques uns des
participants
nous sommes ici pour défendre la liberté
et nous sommes ici pour soutenir les
employés de south west qui défendent
leur droit de travailler sans être forcé
de se faire vacciner sans être forcé de
subir un licenciement en raison de leur
choix médicaux c'est un choix il s'agit
de liberté et il s'agit de défendre nos
droits en tant qu'américains
il est important que nous soyons tous
solidaires et que nous défendions nos
droits inaliénables comme notre
intégrité physique et que le
gouvernement ne nous impose pas les
vaccins contre notre volonté
alors si le sort de lait de ses salariés
de cette compagnie aérienne southwest
airlines et bien été si médiatisé c'est
parce que la semaine dernière la
compagnie a dû annuler des milliers de
vols elle a écarté tout lien entre ces
annulations et la mise en place de
l'obligation de vaccination mais à les
justifications de l'entreprise en
expliquant que ces animations étaient
dus à la météo n'ont pas à réellement
qu'on va hu et d'ailleurs certains ont
mis en avant cette affaire pour
illustrer le fait que la mise en place
de l'obligation de vaccination avait un
impact très réel sur un certain nombre
de secteurs d'activité
l' affaire a pris une telle ampleur que
même le président américain joe biden a
fini par prendre la parole à ce sujet
c'était la semaine dernière écouter
le chef du syndicat des pilotes et le
pdg de southwest airlines ou rejeter
l'accusation que l'obligation vaccinale
contribueraient aux perturbations du
trafic aérien des représentants de
l'éducation des chefs religieux et des
docteurs dans tout le pays lutte contre
la désinformation et sensibilise la
population à l'importance de la
vaccination
tous ces efforts vont nous permettre de
continuer à déplacer le curseur
d'éliminer cette maladie
la question maintenant c'est de savoir
si cette décision de southwest airlines
peut créer un précédent dans une
amérique très divisé sur la question de
l'obligation de vaccination c'est une
division aussi politique puisque vous
avez d'un côté des états républicains
comme le texas par exemple qui ont tout
simplement interdit la mise en place des
obligations de vaccination et dans le
même temps le maire démocrate de la
ville de new york a annoncé ce mercredi
que tous les employés municipaux de la
ville devront maintenant être vaccinés
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des prix de l'essence et
du gasoil qui bat des records en france
le gouvernement doit faire des annonces
un chèque pour les plus modestes une
baisse des tattes plusieurs pistes sont
sur la table rester avec
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique attend ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'elle nous trouve la
peuplent c'était une volonté collectés
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du pays il est clair que tout le monde
attend sable
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez souligne jérôme
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté vous remercie de m'avoir
invité
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant en coule et où ça n'a
plus rien fait pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont il se désintéresserait
en lieu et place de politiser les jeunes
ça dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus que nesc justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
moi ça comme politique personnelle
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
les ong sont devenus en 50 ans des
acteurs incontournables de la société
moderne par leur impact auprès des
gouvernements et du public confondant
régulièrement les grands principes avec
leurs objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le
rationnel le sectarisme de la majorité
d'entre elles les amènent à des
interprétations qui exclut toute pensée
ou comportements n'allant pas dans leur
sens et leur condition n'hésitant pas à
tordre les faits et à utiliser tous les
moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort devait
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une solide et hopitalisé il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai carrefour
un vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage doc est une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière
a ajouté à la scène gastronomique
mondiale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h merci nous rejoignent pour sa
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
les annonces du gouvernement attend de
devenir imminente alors que les prix de
l'essence et du gasoil bat des records
en france un chèque pour les plus
modestes une baisse de tasses plusieurs
pistes sont à l'étude
une flambée des prix d'énergie qui
touche en tout cas toute l'europe
bruxelles réfléchira également ont
demandé mesure
[Musique]
lisez plusieurs pistes envisagées donc
pour lutter contre la hausse des prix du
carburant en attendant les prochaines
heures des mesures concrètes de la part
du gouvernement et des coûts pousse très
attendue par les français qui font face
à une vie de plus en plus cher
l'exécutif hésiterait entre un chèque
pour les plus modestes et une baisse des
taxes à la flambée des prix d'énergie un
véritable casse-tête à l'échelle
européenne
d'ailleurs bruxelles se penchera dès
demain sur ce sujet les états membres de
l'ue eux qui mènent oeuvre pour protéger
leurs consommateurs le point sur les
différentes mesures envisagées par ces
pays avec sébastien rabat face à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie lise
européens se tournent vers leurs
gouvernements respectifs
alors qu'en france les prix de l'essence
et du gasoil bat des records dans
l'ensemble du continent toutes les
contre mesures pour protéger les
consommateurs sont envisagés
en allemagne où la taxe de 54% sur le
sans plomb 95 est parmi les plus élevés
du continent les autorités au visage de
la revoir à la baisse mais cela reste
pure spéculation
le successeur d'angela merkel n'est
toujours pas en poste et jusqu'ici
aucune mesure n'a été prise le
gouvernement sortant se veut rassurant
et prévient que des actions seront
menées si la hausse des prix se poursuit
le royaume-uni envisage de suivre la
même piste que berlin mais doit faire
face à un double problème une hausse des
prix du carburant aggravé par une
pénurie de chauffeurs routiers ces
dernières semaines à la suite du bric
site le gouvernement croate a quant à
lui déjà réagi en adoptant un décret
pour plafonner les prix du carburant
jusqu'à la mi-novembre une mesure
d'ailleurs proposé en france par le
parti communiste mais son précisions sur
sa durée éventuelle quelques états dont
l'italie qui subit une des hausses des
prix de l'essence les plus élevées du
continent n'ont pas encore tranché sur
la marche à suivre la plupart se
tournent donc vers bruxelles en espérant
trouver une solution commune pour le
moment la commission européenne ne s'est
pas prononcé
alors quelles solutions pour faire face
à cette flambée des prix d'énergie
quelle marge de manoeuvre pour le
gouvernement français dans un contexte
européen parfois contraignant lieu
pourra-t-elle adopter des mesures en
commun c'est l'heure de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler pierre
chaze frais en direct a délégué général
de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes bonsoir pierre chef
c'est merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau avec nous également
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
chèque carburant baisse des taxes
bouclier ce sont toutes ces pistes dont
on parle tous les jours dans les médias
qui sont étudiées par le gouvernement
français face à la hausse des prix des
des carburants bout pierre chasserait le
spécialiste de l'automobiliste des
automobilistes vous espérez quelle
mesure qu'ils sortent du chapeau 2 de
jean castex dans la soirée ou demain
probablement
écoutez vous savez s'il est cohérent
étant donné que le projet de baisse de
lait tombé à cinq et demi pour ce temps
c'est la mesure de 40 millions
d'automobilistes qu'on avait soufflé à
l'oreille des candidats qui a d'abord
été reprises par anne hidalgo puis
marine le pen puis eric ciotti puis eric
zemmour et pour finir je prends un autre
candidat team pardonnera vu que c'est
notre proposition je vais soutenir notre
proposition vous ne voudrez pas la
baisse de la tva à 5,5 est la baisse des
détails à verre à 5,5 certes qui est
tout de même au top dans sa maison la
solution peut-être là alors la plus
juste socialement mais la plus coûteuse
aussi pour l'état quand on sait que
alors on en parlera avec kercha srecki
qui n'est pas d'accord mais pourtant
c'est ce que on lit un petit peu partout
donc votre réponse nous intéressera tout
le branchement est ce que en tout cas
dans cette approche le gouvernement est
contraint par plusieurs facteurs si
j'ose dire
dans la classe politique française et à
ceux qui souhaitent une mesure ciblée
pour aider l'infirmière qui a besoin de
circuler en automobile dans la campagne
où tous les gens qui ont absolument
besoin de décence pour pour faire leur
eau leur métier pour pour circuler pour
survivre et puis ceux qui considèrent
qu'ils que c'est trop compliqué que dans
le fond on n'a pas
les fichiers qui permettent de faire
cela et qu'il vaut mieux prendre en
effet une mesure uniforme et par
conséquent agir par le biais de la
fiscalité soit la tva soit l'autre taxe
la taxe bien français la taxe intérieure
sur
l'aller les produits les produits
énergétiques là qui est une taxe assez
élevé qui est d'ailleurs partagée entre
les collectivités territoriales une
petite fraction va à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et le reste va
à l'état donc sur le billet sur le plan
fiscal il ya deux possibilités il ya la
tva et cette taxe spécifique française
est plus élevé que la tva d'ailleurs
et puis il ya les mesures ciblées alors
je crois que la décision n'est
probablement pas encore prise et que le
président de la république se réserve
peut-être de prendre la température à
bruxelles demain au conseil européen
pour voir ce que les uns et les autres
vont dire avant de prendre sa décision
même si dans son for intérieur il sait
dans quelle direction il va on va
évidemment parler avec vous de cet
aspect international qui a son
importance est évidemment dans ce
dossier puisque c'est record au prix des
pompes et de l'énergie va au-delà
évidemment de la france il ya certaines
contraintes européennes pierre chats
seraient alors les taxes à la vuvu
m'intriguer parce qu'on lit très
précisément jeu quand je lisais ce matin
chez nos confrères du parisien si on
augmente non sont réduits de 20 centimes
à la pompe ça fait 500 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires en moins dans les
caisses de l'état vrai ou faux alors
vous savez je vais vous expliquer le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a une
majorité de journalistes qui répète ce
qu'un ministre et qui ne vérifie pas en
fait en économie il y a deux axes il ya
le trop perçu et le manque à gagner ces
deux choses différentes aujourd'hui les
taxes sur les carburants sont au plus
fort
dans l'histoire de france nous n'avons
connu autant de taxes sur les carburants
jallet nous sommes sa 100e sur les prix
à la pompe au dessus de ce qui était
budgété par le gouvernement alors
ensuite c'est un calcul les taxes et 60%
ont fait 60 % de 16 centimes il reste
une dizaine de centimes c'est à dire que
nous sommes dans une situation où l'état
chaque jour perçoit 10 centimes de trop
perçus sur les taxes autrement dit un
centime égale 500 millions là dessus il
a raison un millier brunel bruno le
maire mais ce qu'il a oublié de dire
c'est que on n'est pas dans une
situation où si on baisse les textes ya
un taxi un manque à gagner pour l'état
on est dans une situation où on est dix
centimes au-dessus on ponctionne on
braque c'est un hold up on braque les
automobilistes à hauteur de 5 milliards
de trop chaque année par rapport à ce
qui est budgétée nous sommes dans une
situation de trop perçu alors on va
regarder justement les prier en france
mais aussi au niveau européen
qui sont très haut vous le voyez la
france évidemment 1,63 ça va jusqu'à 1
67 un revenu de 200 plomb en allemagne
en italie aux pays-bas c'est encore pire
quand blanchemaison on le constate parce
qu'on en parle peut-être pas toujours
assez ce problème il est vraiment
mondial européen quelle marge de
manoeuvre au niveau de l'europe est ce
que c'est sur le sol vieillit là qu'il
faut jouer
comme on le sait le prix de l'essence à
la pompe et il est constitué par un
tiers qui représentent le coût de la
production pétrolière
une quantité très faible qui est le coût
du raffinage de à deux et demi pour cent
le raffinage c'est pas très rentable cet
avis pour cent la distribution pour la
mise à disposition dans les stations
service et puis le reste en effet ce
sont les taxes
les taxes c'est une une c'est une part
très importante du prix à la pompe
puisqu'il ya la tva au prix
naturellement la tva au taux normal de
20% et puis cette fameuse taxe
intérieure sur la consommation
énergétique qui est réparti entre trois
parties prenantes
et l'une des parties prenantes même si
c'est dans une faible mesure c'est le
ministère de la transition énergétique
parce que en effet il ya une autre
considération qu'il faut prendre en
compte il ya bien sûr l'intérêt du
consommateur il ya l'intérêt du budget
de l'état mais il ya aussi la transition
énergétique et l'idée est quand même que
à long terme on doit réduire la
consommation d'essence et que par
conséquent tout ce qui constitue à coup
tissus tout ce qui consiste à alléger le
prix de l'essence ne va pas dans ce sens
c'est prenant d'ailleurs pour ça qu'un
certain nombre de nos partenaires
européens ont des prix de l'essence qui
sont plus et nuit encore en france donc
cette discussion elle a lieu
actuellement entre différents membres du
gouvernement est en effet le président
de la république doit arbitrer
probablement après avoir entendu ce que
vont dire ses collègues à bruxelles
demain ce qu'on va dire la commission
mais à bruxelles bruxelles n'a pas de
pouvoir sur ce sur ce sujet puisque tout
ce qui est fiscal et de compétences
nationales et pour le reste ça dépend
des grandes compagnies pétrolières
obtient chasserait on voit s'afficher à
l'écran cette taxe qui représente 50 à
70% des prix du carburant dans
l'ensemble des pays membres de l'union
européenne ça nous inspire quoi vous
j'ai pas pour habitude de regarder
ailleurs comme j'habite dans le pays qui
pratiquent le plus fort taux de
fiscalité sur ces habitants moi je le
connais aussi dépendant de de l'europe
dans ce cas précis de figure
je ne regarde pas la fiscalité est
appliquée regardez l'allemagne des des
blocs 9 milliards pour les énergies pour
les habitants tout globale et encore il
n'ya pas encore les annonces sur les
carburants nous en france on n'a pas
débloqué neuf milliards que je sache
donc pour l'instant on va s'occuper d'un
mobilité me rappellent qu'ils
emportaient une semaine on en pleurerait
les automobilistes de partir en france
sur littoral pour relancer le commerce
relancer la consommation développer
le taux de croissance du pays qui est
basé sur la consommation et donc le pib
donc ce que je m'étonne aujourd'hui
c'est que la bobologie a atteint nos
ministres et que maintenant nous
pointent du doigt en disant on va quand
même pas aider ceux qui partent en et
suivait à la mer bon quand on entend des
propos aussi aussi condescendants de la
farb minière foire le fameux 4 4 en
direction de deauville effectivement on
l'a entendu beaucoup ces derniers jours
dans les médias vous trouvez ça injuste
mais non c'est pas injuste c'est bio
c'est à dire que c'est juste montrer au
public qu'on est bête donc je maintienne
quand même hein on est ministre de
l'économie et des finances et qu'on a
pris pour habitude de pointer du doigt
des français en les montrant du doigt en
les stigmatisant et on les faisant
passer pour des imbéciles ça en dit long
quand même sur ce les personnes qui sont
à la tête de deux pays moi je me pique
les manuels aujourd'hui est atteint du
syndrome du poisson rouge c'est à dire
qu'il a fait trois fois de moins dans
l'elysée depuis maintenant trois ans il
a oublié ce qui s'est passé en 2008
alors faut arrêter de compter les doutes
mandel et se dire que si demain il ya
gilet jaune là ça va coûter de l'argent
à la france et là ça sera du manque à
gagner et pas du trop-perçu deuxième
petit considère un grand jeu quand même
1 43 ans à sète au prize et le
sourire
vous êtes certainement
on peut simplement soutenir une autre
argumentation est ce qu'on veut faire
une mesure sociale est ce qu'on veut
faire une mesure politique est ce qu'on
veut faire une mesure économique alors
effectivement la mesure sociale
semble-t-il très difficile à pratiquer
parce que quelles seraient les
bénéficiaires exactement on risquerait
d'ailleurs dans l'oublié la mesure
uniforme et donc fiscale est en effet
assez séduisante cela dit
on a montré que ça n'a pas beaucoup
relancer la consommation dans les
stations balnéaires et en effet
l'argument disant on fait un cadeau à
tout le monde est un argument qui
probablement sera reprochée au
gouvernement par la gauche peut-être par
la droite aussi est en tout cas par les
écologistes donc là des files de la
décision est très difficile à prendre
pour le pour le pour le président
déficit d'ici demain appiah chasserait
je m'emploie faire des noms long avec la
tête non parce que je regarde
l'échiquier politique m'aperçois qu'à
droite on est favorable à la baisse des
taxes michel barnier vient d'annoncer je
m'aperçois qu'anne hidalgo a été la
première à parler de la baisse des taxes
donc non il ya unanimité si on prend du
côté de la droite à la droite de la
droite du côté d'eric zemmour ou de
marine le pen on est favorable à la
baisse des taxes non non en fait y est
une seule personne en france qui est
défavorable à la baisse des taxes et les
écologistes mais les écologistes c'est
qui
ces personnes le train de prendre des
mesures en la population c'est ça le
principe 95 donc moins besoin de
carburant non pour arrêter un petit peu
de céder à ces chantages vers moi j'ai
l'impression que les verts ils sont
surtout très gris quand ma main et quand
il quand il s'agit de chercher des arts
du monde donc ça c'est une constante non
non ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est de
passer à l'action arrêté un petit peu et
se dire que quand on est président de la
république on est élu par les français
aujourd'hui on sait qu'ils ont portés
manuel macron à la tête de ce pays ont
souhaité souhaite une baisse des taxes
sur le carburant dont acte c'est un
braquage entendre % de taxes comment
peut-on accepter de nos pour qu'un
produit soit taxée à hauteur de 60% et
l'argument écologique faut arrêter faut
arrêter les français achètent les vies
on leur propose si demain on propose aux
français un véhicule économique
électrique avec des pommes des bornes de
recharge pas cher qui vont faire quoi
les français bayrou l'acheter parce que
si demain de coluche 1 si on vous
propose deux paquets de lessive contre
un paquet de lessive les deux paquets
c'est comme ça donc soyons un petit peu
pragmatique
arrêtons de faire des belles phrases
pour plaire à greenberg à glasgow pour
la coop 26 star franchement n'importe
quoi commençons à faire aux politiques
ou les français avant de se paie quand
même d'une minorité de marginaux qui
hormis plombe le pays la bobologie c'est
le cancer de la france qu'un dans ce
présent qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
demain de ce sommet à bruxelles qui va
tenter de voir comment effectivement
joué sur ses records de prix dans toute
l'europe parce que certes on est en
france mais ça concerne la vue sur ce
graphique tout à l'heure je trempais
avant tout les tous les états membres
ont à répondre à ce problème d'abord à
court terme c'est qu'en effet il ya un
pic des prix de l'essence et que ça pose
un problème en effet politique didier
qui risque fort de durer oui enfin on
dit que ça va durer peut-être six mois
il se trouve que comme par hasard ça
correspond à la période électorale parce
que quand même à long terme tout le
monde pense que et d'ailleurs les
compagnies pétrolières elles-mêmes m se
diversifie les compagnies pétrolières
n'investissent plus dans le pétrole
elles n'investissent plus lent gâvres
elle investit dans les énergies
renouvelables total multiplie les
actions dans l'énergie renouvelable ça
veut dire qu'à long terme tout le monde
pense qu'il va falloir évoluer mais en
effet à court terme il y a une pointe à
écrêter et il faut en tenir compte sans
doute pour en effet l'ensemble de la
classe moyenne française donc on a des
espoirs pour demain que ça puisse
répercuter de manière favorable dans
notre pays également c'est le préfet cc
chaque gouvernement national qui prendra
la décision et pourra s'appuyer sur tel
ou tel argument qui aurait été évoquée
évoqué à bruxelles mais ça n'est pas à
bruxelles de prendre la décision ça ne
lui appartient pas puisque la fiscalité
et de compétences nationales et a tendu
un piège à serait justement sur cette
durée vous vous avez bon espoir que les
prix baissent
un horizon de six mois nous disait qu'on
branche maison
coutume il vous a pas échappé que je
suis pas ministre
mais je vous le dis que si demain je
devais faire de la politique quand je
suis sur un sujet aussi tendues que
celui qu'on vit actuellement dans un
contexte on arrive trois ans après les
gilet jaune on a vu quand même notre
pays dans un état même sérieusement à
bochum personne ne veut revivre ça je me
dis qu'il faudra être quand même au fond
dément
touchés on ne pas comprendre qu'on est
dans l'obligation de baisser les taxes
donc la question c'est pas de savoir
nous plier si on fait un chèque
carburant si on teste aussi où cela en
question et d'agir pour ne pas retrouver
notre pays dans un contexte de places
vont s'opposent unes aux autres je n'ai
pas envie de voir des laissés pour
compte dans les basses moyennes qui nous
touchent rien avant quelques
automobilistes qui vont pouvoir
moyennant le dossier où ils vont devoir
limite faire la mendicité pour obtenir
20 euros je ne trouve pas que ce soit
digne d'un état comme la france les
carburants c'est de la mobilité linverse
de la mobilité ça s'appelle le
confinement et le confinement j'ai pas
envie de leur dire donc faut savoir si
on veut la seule âme en clown on sait
tous livrer les produits parce que ça
coûte moins cher et finalement on n'a
pas besoin de sortir de chez soi avec le
carburant le prochain ou alors si on
décide d'avoir un pays qui bouge qui vit
et qui peut se permettre des
déplacements moi perso ma voiture ou
bien vous savez quoi je vais partir avec
mes enfants en vacances et j'ai pas
honte en suis très fier dans des maisons
bruno le maire ministre des finances
devrait peut-être faire que moi
peut-être que ça lui prendra un petit
peu de souvenirs en ce moment il va pas
très bien de quel bord faisant le mot de
la fin ce que clairement des réformes
plus ambitieuses sur le long terme
seront nécessaires d'ailleurs certaines
seront examinées demain à bruxelles il
faut aller dans le sens évidemment
d'urgence mais au delà aussi sur le
pétrole c'est très difficile puisque le
marché est un marché mondial que les
grandes sociétés pétrolières sont des
sociétés qui agissent sur le marché
mondial et par conséquent le cadre
bruxellois est trop étroit pour ces
sociétés dont conséquent ils pompent des
mesures efficaces ne peuvent pas être
prises ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est que justement au niveau mondial le
prix du pétrole à monter
d'ailleurs pour un bon motif c'est parce
que il ya une reprise économique partout
dans le monde après le coc vidé après le
confinement que qu'on a malheureusement
vécu donc cette reprise en effet induit
une augmentation importante de la
demande de pétrole et l'offre a du mal à
suivre probablement que les stocks
n'étaient pas suffisants il ya peut-être
aussi là une responsabilité des sociétés
et des états pour faire face à cette
augmentation importante de la demande
donc il faut probablement que sur ces
sujets les 27 chefs d'état de
gouvernement peuvent
confort qu'ont concerter leurs points de
vue et prendre des orientations mais
encore une fois il reviendra à chaque
état membre pour l'urgence actuelle de
prendre des mesures nationales et puis
pour le reste et bien qu'on le veuille
ou non ce sont les grandes sociétés
pétrolières et les pays producteurs qui
déterminent l'avenir du marché du marché
pétrolier et qui détermine par
conséquent le prix du pétrole est au
bout du compte le prix à la pompe alors
bien sûr on peut on peut le bc en
baissant les taxes s'abaissera les
revenus
des revenus des fils que pourquoi pas
c'est une variable qui probablement
d'ailleurs sera soumise aux électeurs
lors des prochaines élections merci en
tout cas à tous dès de mercy que la
branche saison merci beaucoup pia
chaufferait d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale ces dizaines
d'arrestations nigeria aujourd'hui
c'était lors de rassemblements pour
rendre hommage un an après aux victimes
de la répression policière du mouvement
hashtag ensas une mobilisation pour
dénoncer la mauvaise gestion de la
gestion du coc bid et la brutalité les
forces de l'ordre sur ces protestations
avec quentin voeckler
l'émotion toujours intacte un an après
la fusillade du péage de l'est qui les
blessés ont toujours en tête cette
journée du 20 octobre 2020
j'étais au péage de l'équipe le 20
octobre 2020 un jour que je ne pourrai
jamais oublier de toute ma vie
le jour où le gouvernement du nigeria a
envoyé l'armée et la police pour tuer
ses citoyens et des manifestants
pacifiques au péage de l'équipe parce
que nous manifestions pour nos droits
en pleine manifestation pacifique contre
une unité de police accusés de racket
d'arrestations illégales et de meurtre
contre la population l'armée reçoit
l'ordre d'ouvrir le feu contre les
manifestants alors acculé au péage de
l'équipe
au moins dix nigérians y perdront la vie
des dizaines d'autres seront blessés
les soldats qui m'ont tiré dessus était
à environ 10 ou 100 mètres de moi ou
quelque chose comme ça je suppose parce
que je peux voir trois de ses militaires
devant moi qui tire sporadiquement il ya
donc une barricade devant moi alors que
nous grandissions tous notre drapeau
national en pensons qu'ils finiraient
par s'adresser à nous et repartirait
mais pourquoi tirer tirer d'un coup ou
nous on fait face directement et ont
commencé à tirer sur les manifestants
comptons
un an plus tard aucun responsable de la
fusillade n'a été traduit en justice une
commission d' enquête judiciaire a été
créée pour examiner les questions
relatives à la manifestation devant
cette assemblée l'armée a déclaré
n'avoir utilisé que des balles à blanc
mais a admis que certains soldats
possédait des balles réelles dans un
rapport publié ce mardi l' ong human
rights watch appelle les autorités
nigérianes à rétablir la justice les
autorités nigérianes devrait prendre des
mesures concrètes et décisives pour
garantir que les personnes impliquées
dans les exactions contre les
manifestants seront tenus pour
responsables les soldats ont piégé les
manifestants en utilisant une tactique
connue sous le nom de kate ling puis ont
tiré en l'air et sur la foule le
kettling est une méthode de confinement
utilisés par la police pour piéger une
foule de personnes dans un espace
spécifique s'il s'est arrêté après la
fusillade le mouvement nbaers n'a pas
dit son dernier mot pour lutter contre
les abus policiers et contre la lenteur
du système judiciaire nigérian est
toujours sur le continent africain la
tunisie a été choisie pour accueillir la
8e édition de la conférence
internationale de tokyo pour le
développement de l'afrique après le
kenya en 2016 c'est la deuxième fois
qu'un tel événement est organisé sur le
continent tunis qui a désormais un nom
on se préparer à accueillir ce
rendez-vous les précisions de notre
correspondant bassem chez nous la
tunisie et porte d'entrée des
investisseurs japonais en afrique c'est
en tout cas l'objectif que s'est fixé
tunis dans le cadre de cette huitième et
eddy si on de la conférence
internationale de tokyo pour le
développement de l'afrique qui se
tiendra en tunisie l'année prochaine
dans une économie plombée par une crise
politique et sociale sans précédent le
secteur privé tunisien entend bien
mettre en valeur le potentiel
scientifique industrielle du pays lors
de cet événement international qui
devrait réunir pas moins de douze mille
dhs hommes aident à faire pour la
sélection tunisienne de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie tuniso japonaise
l'arrivée de nouveaux investisseurs
japonais pourrait être l'occasion de
promouvoir la jeunesse du pays frappé
par la malédiction de l'exode et dont le
potentiel demeure inexploitée par les
institutions du pays il nous en manque
de synchronisation peu de potentiel
tunisien et
les orientations de l'état en se levant
investissement c'est à dire le potentiel
tunisien a été du moins a été découvert
par nos amis japonais durant le
séminaire dont nous avons déjà établi et
au pire tout organiser ils sont vraiment
surpris d'apprendre qu'il ya un
potentiel assez important de jeunes
surtout dans les nouvelles technologies
d'intelligence artificielle et digital
et tout ça qui est un potentiel jédir et
inexploité part des autorités
tunisiennes sur le plan engagements
d'investissement que nous sommes
toujours ce plat classique
d'investissement il ya eu quelques
activités pour encourager ce genre de
non c'est pas assez tenant compte du
potentiel du pays les japonais sont très
très conscient de ce point fort en marge
de cette annonce l'ambassadeur du japon
en tunisie a déclaré que l'organisation
de cette conférence constitue est un
challenge pour la jeune démocratie
fragilisé tout en précisant que cinq
projets japonais était en cours de
réalisation en tunisie avec à la clé
plus de cinq mille créations d'emplois
il a appelé tunis à améliorer le climat
d'investissement et économique
conditions si l'économie pour renforcer
la présence des investisseurs japonais
en tunisie en pleine crise financière
est confrontée à un déficit budgétaire
historique la tunisie espère grâce à
cette 8e édition de la conférence
internationale de tokyo pour le
développement en afrique renouer avec
ses partenaires étrangers de quoi peut
être donner un souffle nouveau à son
économie en berne pressez la fin
émission merci d'avoir suivi rendez vous
demain dès 20 heures d'ici là n'oubliez
pas de réagir sur notre compte et les
grammaires t france et l'actualité
continue toute la soirée
[Musique]
le résultat d'un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai carrefour
un vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc à une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière
a ajouté à la scène gastronomique
mondiale
[Musique]
président à vie en perdre la vie pascal
affi n'guessan quelles sont les raisons
qui poussent les chefs d'état à se
maintenir au pouvoir en afrique ce n'est
pas seulement parce que ses chefs on
essaie de tendance cette volonté de
rester mais ça passe car en face il n'y
a pas de quoi des contre-pouvoirs
suffisamment fort et le premier contre
le pouvoir c'est le plus pourquoi
l'organisation d'élections transparentes
reste toujours un défi sur le continent
africain est encore beaucoup de pays
africains une forte proportion de la
population qui attachés à la question
technique donc qui ne sont pas encore
acquises à la démocratie est ce que vous
serez candidat en 2025 et est ce que si
vous deviez l'emporter vous promettez
justement de ne jamais briguer un
troisième mandat s'il valait mieux pas
de la tnb
50 cc c'est le temps qu'il nous faudra
qu'un seul mandat on retient sata promet
sa cascade qui descend
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tout
petit écho politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des lignes ans aujourd'hui une
gauche 6 13 ans
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview
[Musique]
l'humanité n'a jamais vu de phénomènes
naturels aussi étrange des cratères
géants apparaissent dans la péninsule de
yamal
les uns après les autres
oui là tu frappes juste contre le bord
tout et je ne vais pas y descendre donc
il doit y avoir une piste axial mais
celui ci est apparue en 2020
de nouveaux arrivants à quelle fréquence
et où de nouveaux cratères à part être
content il va tourner vas-y à quel point
sont ils dangereux pour les humains
moi-même et revient de la famille van ou
mytho en 2021 les scientifiques russes
sont sur le point de trouver une réponse
à ce mystère
ils ont construit un modèle 3d d'un
cratère de yamal
[Musique]